وفق صحيفه جراند
حفره اسماء صوفيا وماريا ومارك وارتيم على
صداره ترتيب الاسماء الاكثر شعبيه للاطفال
الاوكرانيين
تؤكد وزاره العدل الاوكرانيه انه لا يوجد
في اوكرانيا اي قيود او حظر على اختيار
الاسماء الاولى
اطفالهم بعد الاسماء التي نادرا لا تستخدم
مثلك التي يرتبط بالمؤسس الاسطوري لمدينه
كييف لكن اشهر هذه الاسماء العسكريه ان صح
التعبير لمواليد اوكرانيا
الجددلينا وهو اسم اختاره الاوكرانيون
تكريما لصاروخ جاب لنا الامريكيه للدبابات
وهناك من الاوكرانيين من اختار اسم باير
كتار نسبه الى المسيره التركيه برقدار وهي
من الاسلحه التي استخدمتها القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بنجاح ضد القوات الروسيه اذا
انتشار هذه الظاهره قدمت وزاره العدل
الاوكرانيا نصيحه للاولياء بالتحلي قدر
الامكان بالمسؤوليه عند اتخاذ قرار بشان
تسميه اطفالهم قائله ان الاسم يؤثر على
مصير الانسان